salut ô oui bienvenue dans ce premier
épisode de t'imagines si bercy
eh ben ça fait plaisir et on va parler
sexe j'ai posé une question aux gens
ouais enfin on l'a on avait réfléchi
ensemble c'était t'imagines si il n'ya
plus d'hommes plus de femmes mais qu'on
est tous ensemble un troisième sexe
insectes unique un sexe mois puisqu'en
fait dans les commentaires il ya eu pas
mal de débats sur le sexe genre etc
c'est que ces deux genres c'est pas
pareil parce que le sexe c'est la
réalité biologique qui sous-tend nos
identités pour le dire correctement et
surtout ce qui définit si on est un
homme ou une femme c'est le type de
gamètes qu'on produit donc si on fait
des spermatozoïdes ou si on fait des
ovules c'est surtout sans quelques trucs
ok avec toutes les exceptions qui existe
parce qu'il ya peu un type de cas
biologique où les gens le genre c'est la
perception qu'on a de notre identité
dans le monde social quoi donc en gros c
est ce que je me sens femme ou est ce
que je me sens donc ça c'est peut être
complètement déconnecté de busby logique
de l'utérus mais nous pouvons sentir à
l'aise et le sexe on a parlé de leurs
perceptions sociales vous ne la parle
pas de la perception psychologique
les gens ont donné des pistes de
réflexion balayant son pièce t'imagines
si il n'y a pas encore de génériques
mais ça arrive tu imagines si le 23e
sexe [ __ ] merde plus d'homophobe plus
de sexisme tous les cons se rabattrait
sur le racisme et pour bâtir ici il n'y
avait pas des caméras c'est qu'on a
essayé un troisième sexe basse il ya
plus qu'un sexe on développerait des
coquilles et on se mettrait à ramper par
terre
vous annoncez une vanne parce que les
escargots y aille s alors non non non
ah ouais la noël bull lance t-il pas
d'accord ok ok ok ce fait qu'il y ait
plus de différences de sexe
donc en fait il est plus de sexe parce
que le sexe se définit par plusieurs sex
que je suis claire en fait si tu as un
sol sec la plus de s'excuser
en gros le sexe à la base en fait le
sexe
base de la base c'est du partage de
gênes les bactéries font du sexe au fil
des jeunes c'est celui-là que et elles
se passent par des piles y par exemple
ça s'appelle 2010 et des tubes et une
bactérie fait un tube et elle connecte
un lot de bactéries et aux quêtes l
image et du goût et les jeunes qui se
trimballe à travers le tube et l'autre
guéri
donc ça c'est du sexe le sexe chez nous
c'est il ya un mâle et une femelle et
donc il ya deux types différents de
gamètes les armes aphrodite ont aussi de
type différentes gammes info d'escargots
par exemple les gens qui moi je sais
c'est pour les gens qui peuvent vrai
qu'il peut parfaite c'est des animaux
qui peuvent changer de sexe typiquement
sur les huîtres j'en ai aucune idée
ah je pensais que les suisses tripous à
la tête mais ça tous ces exemples là j'y
connais rien je connais rien au
biologique en fait mais le truc c'est
que tu as comme des animaux qui change
par exemple de sexe qu'on leur vie ou
qui peuvent se reproduire et les
escargots pas faire ça ouais enfin bon
je sais pas si c'est toutes les espèces
d'escargots parce qu'il y avait quand
même pas mal mais oui enfin ils sont
connus pour ça t'imagines si on était
tous là même sexe genre asexué unique
alors c'est ouf no way
incroyable donc tu aurais naissance de
nouvelles alors l'apparition d'un genre
unique naissance de nouvelles positions
sexuelles moins d'inégalités -
discrimination même problème pour les
castings de films de cul bon ok là
j'abuse non ça va moins de problèmes
d'homophobie et surtout la joie des
communistes ceci était un commentaire
what the fuck apprendre millième degré
avec un s au connacht 23 clubs
ça c'est drôle ça dépend vraiment de
la gueule corée ce troisième sexe si on
avait les mêmes à un tommy ce sera
peut-être moins riches
on va regarder si les homosexuels au
moins y aurait sans doute qu'il y aurait
sans doute un organe pour mettre à
l'intérieur un organe pour recevoir
alors s'il ya la forme on garde notre
tuquoi absolument qu'on garde l'anus
oui tiens on peut ok pour innover ça
c'est que la ligne e fax escardes
gardons un trou mais toi genre même toit
genre deux trous
si les deux trous sont difficiles à
atteindre c'est compliqué tu vois c'est
compliqué donc ouais peut-être que
peut-être que red pas tant qu'il ne
serait pas même pas le jouissif en fait
par contre ceci sur l'anatomie de ces
chalets synthèse les vagins ça marche
parce que bah c'est facilement
accessible et donc elles peuvent frotter
leurs agents par exemple c'est ce que je
dis j'imagine c'était juste l'anus votre
parti sexuelle et genres fallait se
frotter l'anus hyper galère ba1 crois
qu'en fait ça c'est chez les hauts mais
les oiseaux à l'aide sociale
votre anus les mêmes des bonnes fait ce
web 1 se disent pas très belle sans
doute l'effet qu'il souhaiterait donc
six disparaîtrait maj non enfin il ya
quand même des muscles manon qui
concerne ça aussi à la locomotion tu vas
tu as besoin d'avoir des gros muscles
des eaux grosses cuisses pour marcher
quoi est ce que par exemple le pénis
disparaîtrait parce que si on a juste
besoin afin de s'échanger du matériel
génétique parce que on a quand même
besoin de cet échange du matériel
génétique quelques colliers perdurer
voilà exactement je prendrais c'est que
ces insectes c'est que juste essayé de
créer des trucs nouveaux pour éviter que
tout le monde leur si jamais il ya un
parasite qui arrive
du coup on a besoin du père n'aura plus
besoin du pénis et ben ouais on pourrait
on pourrait faire mal enfin différentes
on reçoit tout le monde avait un pénis
et un vagin pourrait à la fois se faire
pénétrer des pénétrer oui ou alors on a
plus que un truc qui nous permet de sa
colle et s'échanger déjà une quoi [ __ ]
ou alors il ya des gens qui pondent des
oeufs et gens s'assoient dessus et
récupère les oeufs et parfois desoblin
jane enfin pu imaginer un truc hein il
n'y a pas mal d'exemples
dans le genre de truc assez sympa on
peut et va comme des bactéries on se
fait un petit pipi sexuelle toi tu
manges c'est pour être un câble qu'on
achète genre msb quoi ouais c'est fou
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un tournant
avec ce câble qu'on l'a sacré est-ce que
tu imagines si avec un troisième sexe un
troisième sexe du coup plus le même
système de reproduction du coup
imaginons qu'il n'y aurait plus de
plaisir à la reproduction du coup les
gens ne font plus d'enfants à chausser
plus l'enfant un jeu y'a pas le hèle un
jeu je lis comme c'est écrit
les gens ne font plus d'enfants du coup
on a sauvé la terre des 7 milliards
d'humains du coup on a résolu problème
de la surpopulation de léo 13 minutes de
vidéo pour ça les eaux vraiment aller
rend l'argent en fait c'est que on a
tendance à croire que le sexe est
forcément obligatoire pour faire de la
reproduction et c'est paca le sexe est
une invention y avait pas de sexe
picard d'un tel sexe est incroyable ou
7,9
c'est c'est exactement c'est marie curie
hockey balèze qui a aussi inventé le
curry auquel étincelles 19 elle a tout
fait quoi les deux meilleures choses de
l'humanité au curry et sec
est-ce qu'elle a inventé les bains mari
aussi ouais au curry ouais ok il faut
s'arrêter
pourquoi est-ce que le sexe est agréable
c'est que c'est une récompense qui est
évidente c'est à dire que imagine un
monde
tu parles d'un monde dans lequel tous
les gens qui se reproduisent il trouve
ça chiant ce repreneur japon c'est pas
agréable machin et là d'un coup y'a un
mec qui naît avec une notation qui rend
le sexe hyper agréable mais alors lui me
va passer sa vie à faire ça la vie
tronçon chalabi trouve toujours un
chemin ils ont dépensé sans compter
une phrase de charles ses potes tu
imagines si genre on n'était pas homme
ou femme et un troisième sexe sexe
unique mais le désir sexuel est
nécessaire pour l'être humain il
existerait forcément il procure est
forcément un plaisir qu'il soit là
forcément d'un orgasme une espèce qui ne
met pas se reproduire ne peut pas
exister tout simplement je pense heures
vrai il ya quand même enfin le plaisir
les circuit de la récompense tout ça
c'est juste chez ceux qui ont un système
nerveux donc une toute petite partie du
monde vivant en fait les plantes n'ont
pas forcément d'orgasme aux récompenses
du que je sache
mais voeckler - elles le font que ça
marche aussi bon moi je chipote la vie
trop songe toujours un chemin ils ont
dépensé sans compter
merci t'imagines si il est plus qu un
troisième sexe [ __ ] c'est une bonne
question ça eh ben je pense qu'on aurait
pu les féministes donc le sexe ne
pourrait plus être sujet à des
stéréotypes
du coup les gens auront beaucoup moins
de mal à faire ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire ce qu'on dise sans réfléchir aux
mains à autre chose on trouvera là on
trouvera toujours des trucs pour
discriminer t'imagines si il y aurait
plus qu'un troisième sexe et vinci avec
un seul sexe le complexe d'oedipe aurait
été dur à imaginer
freud ce serait peut-être mis à faire de
la vraie science du coup je sais pas si
tu as parlé de [ __ ] ta mère
même si même si ta mère est pareil que
toi je vois pas trop pourquoi ça
changerait elle en fait et en plus tu
pourras unique et on perd parce qu'il
n'est pas à ce qu'on dit de la merde
ouais c'est possible de les voir les
chaînes de psychologie type le pilote et
ce commentaire est écrit par kinect bah
oui je l'expliqué lui-même une chaîne de
psychologie qu'il est vachement bien
c'est quelqu'un de bien tu imagines si
genre il y avait un troisième sexe c'est
fini ouais
ces noms déjà merci merci beaucoup à
tout commentaire c'est cool plus au
groupe deux jours plusieurs mâles entend
donc là c'est dans le cas où ça se
passerait d'un claquement de quoi
commencer
franchement je suis même pas sûr que la
comédie les manifestants gay manifestent
leur joie lorsque vraiment à l'aise je
pense que personne très contente donc de
l'aspect le plus intéressant à c'est
vraiment le côté économique est ce qu on
serait tous plus riches
moi je pense que je pense que le
féminisme coûte très cher le sexisme
coûte très cher oulala le lapsus ou la
hanche il ya une bonne moitié de la
population qui est sous utilisé en fait
elles se paient tu vas débat sous payés
et puis en fait quand tu ce pays
quelqu'un ils le payent moins bien tu le
forme moins bien enfin la moitié des
cerveaux de du monde qu'ils sont moins
bien formés que l'autre moitié est cédée
1001 tu vas avoir tellement plus de
géants mulhouse on nous en parle pas de
petit écart en france l'écart entre les
salaires hommes femmes en poste égal
c'était important
j'avais entendu beaucoup parler de 30%
mais je ne sais pas dans quel domaine
auquel saint-gilles osa j'ai vu ça sur
france info de plus avant le sexe ne
plus avoir de sexisme je pense que ça
générerait énormément que tu en fait
dans ce pack or
surtout si c'est un truc qui ait jamais
existé avant tu vois well as tu n'as
mais là c'était donc à vous inviter à
ces listes peut-être les premières
générations les journées seront quand
même absolument trouver une différence
de genre parce qu'ils sont habitués mais
leur thème le rose est alors ok -19% sur
le salaire mais là ça cesse a dit aux
gens quoi 50 ans 200 chasse d'eau une
chaise de chasse d'eau t'imagines si
genre ont été 1 section unique tous
ouais ensemble alors peut-être qu'il
existerait toujours des inégalités
sociales mais basée sur d'autres
critères que le genre ce troisième sexe
ne changerait rien par exemple aux
inégalités blanc noir que l'on peut
retrouver dans plusieurs pays dans
l'avocat y compris en antarctique où les
manchots sont pleins
ouais ouais on va continuer du coup tu
es tu imagines si genre y avait pas
d'homme de faim mais qu'en fait genre d
un troisième cycle genre un sexe la
tunique quoi jean noël diouf alors
réponse de john duff prouver que c'est
bien lui 26 assez l'omelette l'industrie
du porno va complètement se casser la
gueule non parce que ben y'a du plan
d'eau avec des gens qui ont de même sexe
du coup du porno avec des gens pareils
ça existe déjà et ça se vend très bien
ne vois pas pourquoi ça marchera plus si
tout le monde est pareil mais elle assez
intéressant mais plus de mst aussi du
coup ça équilibre un petit peu alors non
parce que en fait le mec a tout faux en
fait non jaune d'oeuf
tu t'es embrouillé oui oui il a fait un
plat oui oui la question quel show et il
est peu hachée et oui il l'a ou pas il à
la coque à mstc quoi lasser des
parasites des virus des champignons les
chlamydias ces champignons
pourquoi est ce qu'on peut penser que ça
y est
on continuerait à se reproduire
justement chez des levures t'as pas de
différence et pas de sexe en fait y'a
pas de mal femelle des individus qui
sont tous pareils et fusionnent et ils
font quand même il faut connaître du
sexe dire il faut quand même de
l'échangé génétique même s'il n'y a pas
de sexe même s'il ya pas de mal les
femelles et chez ces gens là il ya quand
même
elles ont quand même des parasites
raison qu'un milieu parce que les vieux
c'est quoi c'est un truc qui va
t'attaquer pour pouvoir survivre
belle même si on s'échange si on
s'échange des jeunes des même s'il ya
plus mal faiblesse et listera quand même
quoi donc il y aura quand même des mst
parce que je suis claire
c'est très très clair et justement des
genres a maintenant fait c'est cette
émission c'est enfin ce format et genre
j'ai l'impression d'être au stage
accueille quelqu'un et je j'apprends en
même temps clairement il y aura encore
des parades et les mst des eaux des
zones odeo parce que ça fait partie
aussi de les refaire si la vie trouve
toujours un chemin mais ils ont dépensé
sans compter
c'est à plus mais coupat clairement
c'est vrai car mon top 5 ans
oui ça fait plaisir tarbes vachement
plaisir c'était bien je reviendrai c'est
vrai ouais et ben vas-y bouge je
t'inviterai aller avec plaisir et le
plaisir en trouvant un autre thème un
hôtel sympa merci merci beaucoup pour
toutes vos questions enfin toutes vos
réponses plutôt c'était vachement
pertinent vachement intéressant y avait
pas mal de tri à faire et du coup on
s'est bien marré et des trucs drôles
enfin c'était c'était très cool et vous
avez vachement bien joué le jeu et ouais
c'était pertinent donc
merci et bravo à wall c'était cool les
commentaires sont sympas et hyper
constructive du coup c'est une bonne
émission hausse en l'air qui tu veux
faire c'est vrai mais je pense tout bas
j'espère aussi j'étais en train de
prendre forme un petit peu et comme je
disais hors caméra c'est aussi avec la
manière dont on a interagi ensemble que
ça impacte sur dix jours le trucage
simplice définit un peu par lui-même le
prochain d'ailleurs ce sera avec dr
nordmann et je vais vous poser la
question dès maintenant tu imagines si
on avait tous une imprimante 3d chez soi
qui permettait de tout imprimé vraiment
tout répond daisy dans les commentaires
de la vidéo sur youtube
voilà ça c'est que les commentaires de
la vidéo sur youtube
ok donc répondit à fond jouer le jeu à
fond et c'est grâce à vous que ce format
peut exister la plus bisous ciao me veil